[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
viele haben sich ja eine oster torte
gewünscht also habe ich mir überlegt
mache ich einen ostereier osterhasen
oder eine 3d karotte und ich habe mich
letztendlich doch für das osterei
entschieden weil denke ich in der
umsetzung ganz einfach ist und man es
wirklich auch individuell komplett aus
gestalten kann
ich mache jetzt zuerst mal einen kuchen
backt das ganze in runden formen also in
meinem back ring und dann wird es später
aber so ein 3 d 1
ich mache heute den teig und den kuchen
las dann bis morgen abkühlen und morgen
geht so einfach mit der deko weiter für
den rückraum verwende ich sechs eier 300
gramm zucker eine prise salz 300 gramm
eierlikör 300 gramm sonnenblumenöl 450
gramm mehl ein päckchen backpulver das
sind drei teelöffel und 200 gramm
mandeln
ich verwende jetzt ganze mandeln die
nehme ich ja zum backen immer ganz gerne
ich mache jetzt einfach kurz mit der
trommel reibe aber ihr könnt natürlich
auch mixa verwenden
[Musik]
die mandeln stelle ich kurz zur seite
jetzt kann ich zuerst die eier verrühren
mit dem zucker und salz schon so etwa
fünf bis sieben minuten richtig schön
cremig und da ist es immer am besten
wenn die eier zimmer warm sind
und wenn man das salz verschüttet
o
[Musik]
jetzt ist die eier zucker mal so schön
weiß schau mich und ich kann jetzt die
beiden flüssigkeiten einfach kurz
verrühren und hier kurz ein rückwärtiger
stufe das mehl habe ich jetzt auch schon
mit backpulver eingefüllt das wird dann
gleich dazu gesagt es gebe ich hier noch
kurz den mandeln dazu und dann eben
gleichbetroffenen zu tragen und jetzt
aber wirklich nicht mehr zu lange röhren
am besten die mandeln noch mit handtuch
mit der küchenmaschine einrühren oder
mit dem handstück gerät und das mehl
dann kurz mit einem schneebesen
unterheben
[Musik]
es ist alles perfekt verrührt es reicht
es auch schon wenn man jetzt nämlich zu
lange rührt vor allem mit der
küchenmaschine oder mit dem anderen
gerät dann wird der kuchen später
schrecklich und das wollen wir nicht
ich will dass das schön luftig und
locker wird jetzt habe ich hier schon
zwei back ringe vorbereitet und auch in
backpapier eingeschlagen da der teig
eben relativ flüssig ist und dann kann
er eventuell auslaufen der hier ist es
26 zentimeter groß der 22 ich teile das
nochmal auf und dann werden gleich beide
gleichzeitig gebacken und ich schauten
einfach mal wie hoch sie werden
denn ich glaube ich muss noch mal eine
portion teig zubereiten nochmal böden
backen denn ich will schon frei machen
ich habe ich gucke jetzt erstmal so nach
der hälfte der backzeit rein wie es
aussieht und dann mache ich noch mal
eine portion teig
hier so ein bisschen nach außen
streichen
dann geht auch schön gleichmäßig auf
[Musik]
gestern habe ich noch mal zwei
tortenböden gebackenen 30 und 21 er also
dass ich noch mal einen größeren und
kleineren durchmesser habe mit der
gleichen menge also mit sechs eiern und
den übrigen zutaten und ich habe noch
eine weiße gala zu bereitet da gibt es
auch bereits auf einem kanal und rezept
dazu das einfach ein basic rezept weiße
ganz einfach aus weißer schokolade und
sahne wird es hergestellt und ich hab's
abgedeckt und bei raumtemperatur einfach
stehen lassen
das haben wir schon mal die tortenböden
habe ich auch abgedeckt nach dem
abkühlen
die sind jetzt gerade im kühlschrank
damit sie sich gleich besser schneiden
lassen und jetzt gibt's noch eine
leckere fruchtige creme so eine art käse
sahne
ich denke passt ganz gut dazu und ich
will einfach was leichtes fruchtiges
drin haben
dafür brauche ich damit 750 gramm
magerquark 100 gramm puderzucker etwas
vanille extrakt und den abrieb
elektronen da brauche ich nur eine prise
900 gramm sahne etwas dünner bart und
zum film noch fair sicher aus der dose
und die pfirsiche habe ich jetzt bereits
abtropfen lassen und kann jetzt hier
schon mal die creme zu bereiten
das heißt ich geb den quartieren die
rührschüssel ihr könnt wenn ihr es vom
füllen her etwas einfacher haben wollt
für euch könnt ihr auch einfach eine
buttercreme machen oder die torte mit
ghanas film dies dann also ich finde
buttercremetorte sehr lecker manche
mögen es nicht so sehr deswegen habe ich
gedacht mach' ich hatte mal ne sahne
creme aber das muss man dann halt schon
so isolieren dass diese creme nicht an
den von dann dran kommt sonst lässt sich
davon und auch sehen muss man da ein
bisschen aufpassen aber das zeige ich
euch gleich es gebe ich hier den
puderzucker dazu bisschen vanille
extrakt und hier noch eine prise
zitronen ab blieb da müsst ihr unbedingt
darauf achten dass die zitronenschale
zum verzehr geeignet ist steht meist
dabei
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die zutaten schon mal
kurz verrühren
[Musik]
und sobald sich alles schön verbunden
rat kommt jetzt hier die sonne langsam
dazu
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier pro 100 gramm
flüssiger masse ein teelöffel seiner
partner zum start schlagen und schlimm
da immer so einen metzler füttern weil
ich nämlich immer ganz genau wie viel
menge ich brauche und vor allem ist es
halt immer einheitlich da immer so ein
gestrichener mesz löffel einen teelöffel
hat man immer die einheitliche menge
[Musik]
jetzt ist die creme perfekt stell dir
jetzt ganz kühl kann in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die vier sicher in kleine
würfel schneiden und die tortenböden
herauslösen und beschneiden
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt den tortenring
bereits abgelöst
und dann könnt ihr ganz einfach den
boden so stürzen und das backpapier
abziehen
[Musik]
und dann hier einfach mit der torten
segelt durchschneiden
ich würde sagen ich mache mir jetzt
nicht zu viel arbeit also halbjährig
sind nur einmal
[Musik]
tapezieren halbes ei auf einen karton
gezeichnet so als schablone und
übertragt das jetzt hier einfach auf
eine platte und dann habe ich einfach
gleich bisschen habe ich ein bisschen
einfacher beim füllen der torte ihr
könnt auch eine charta platte nehmen als
es so eine leicht schaum platte die
lässt sich nämlich mit einem skalpell
einer ordermesse einfach zu schneiden
habe ich jetzt keine mehr übrig daher
mache ich das jetzt kurz mit der
stichsäge
[Musik]
den rest würde ich einfach kurzschlaf
das noch kurz weg und dann okay ist es
in diesen eigen geworden aber egal den
rest
[Musik]
so ein bisschen sauber machen und dann
kann ich jetzt die torte da drauf füllen
ich hab das alles schön sauber gemacht
und meine vorstellung war jetzt ich habs
jetzt moment waagerecht schon halbiert
jetzt habe ich die böden einmal noch so
dass halbkreise entstehen
und ich habe jetzt die vier größen und
ich hoffe es klappt jetzt alles so aber
ich denke schon ich mal niedrig und wie
gesagt ist jetzt nur die problematik
betrifft wirklich keine quarkcreme außen
an den vom land lassen
also werden wir das ganze mit garage
isolieren dem garage davon dann tauglich
das passt ganz gut
ok starte ich habe jetzt hier im
spritzbeutel mit einer lok thüle da
kommt jetzt die gerne schreiben
die hat es hier so eine konstanz ist
noch ein bisschen weich die dürfte etwas
fester sein aber auch nicht zu fest aber
das kriegen wir gleich hin die wird auch
gleich fest da ja die sahne creme kalt
ist danach steht nämlich super schnell
an
so sieht vorne die lufthülle aus dann
gebe ich jetzt hier einfach mal außen
rum wie so ein ring danach drauf
ich hab mal mit dem kleinsten angefangen
kann er wenigstens schief gehen jetzt
kommt sie etwas creme rein
[Musik]
gebe ich hier noch vier sicher drauf
statt vier sicher könnt ihr auch
saisonales obst nehmen aber es einfach
ein bisschen schwierig noch im frühjahr
da wächst noch nicht so viel regional
daher könnte da gerne auf dosenfrüchten
zurückgreifen oder gefriergetrocknete
früchte gefrorene sind nicht so gut weil
gibt frauen früchte einfach im innern
dann aufbauen und wirklich sehr matschig
werden oder ihr kocht sie ein und gibt
sie mit in die creme so ich bin jetzt
aber auch nur an kleinen ring machen und
bisschen creme drauf damit packe ich
jetzt sozusagen die früchte ein
[Musik]
aber ausprobieren also jetzt hochkam
stellen
ich glaube dann könnt ihr euch
vorstellen was ich hier gerade bauen und
dann hab ich nämlich schon mal schön
diese rundung hier
es wird später zwar noch zugeschnitten
aber ich mache jetzt einmal das hier
jetzt nämlich die größe größer und das
behalte ich noch mal als puffer für hier
vorne ist muss ich nämlich zu schneiden
und hier mache ich jetzt genau das
gleiche mit allen vier größen jetzt
erstmal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz zum
hintergrund wieso ist es gerade so etwas
aufwendiger gestaltet wird also torten
schmecken am besten wenn sie fruchtig
und frisch und schön saftig sind so uns
zumindest und deswegen mache ich hier
gerne diese käse sahne creme diese käse
sahne creme die darf aber nicht in
berührung mit vom land kommen denn
fondant besteht ja zu 98 prozent aus
zucker und die flüssigkeit hier drin
also diese feuchtigkeit die sahne der
quark wird einfach den fondant auflösen
daher nehme ich diese weise kann also
diese schokoladencreme als
isolierschicht wie beim hausbau
sozusagen bevor die fassade dran kommt
kommt die kanalstr unter die hält die
feuchtigkeit schön ihnen im haus okay im
haus wesen bisschen schwierig oder
bisschen kontraproduktiv aber in der
torte möchte ich die feuchtigkeit in der
torte haben außen die gage und dann eben
schön die von dann decke später drüber
ihr könnt wenn ihr es einfacher haben
wollt jetzt einfach die komplette torte
mit ghana spiel mit einer dunklen
schokoladen garage oder einer swissmedic
oder italienischen buttercreme die sind
nämlich auch von dann tauglich aber ich
finde hier passiert so eine fruchtige
quark sahne creme schon besser und
deswegen mache ich das jetzt hier so
aber wenn jetzt einfacher machen wollt
füllt sie einfach mit ghana dann hat man
nämlich gar kein problem jetzt alles
bisschen weiter nach vorne
denn es soll ich hier in der mitte die
höchste stelle haben
das passt so ganz gut wenn ich mir das
nur von der seite anschauen hinten darf
jetzt wieder flacher werden dann nehme
ich den großen netzen nicht mehr sondern
ja fast nur von vorne auch mit dem dran
und die größe nummer zwei und größe
nummer eins rechts nimmt das wir
schneide ich hier noch zu recht okay
das heißt ich hätte jetzt nur den großen
halben übrig das passt aber ganz gut da
können wir immer ganz gut rumkugeln
draus machen oder so kleine kokos kugeln
euch hier nochmal
perfekt ich zeige euch gleich eine
resteverwertung oder noch mal ein
kleiner
ich habe mich eine klippe und die
dazwischen die klebe ich jetzt einfach
mit etwas gar nichts zusammen
dann nämlich jetzt keine quark sahne die
garage stehen wir doch immer schön fest
sobald sie kalt ist daher hier jetzt
einfach ein bisschen was nehmen drauf
streichen und dann habe ich die torte
sofort stabil und eben schön fest
zusammen
[Musik]
ich hatte tatsächlich kurz überlegt
damit surprise verein zu machen aber das
sprengt dann alle dimensionen also das
ist schon aufwendig genug für die oster
torte das machen wir dann mal ab wenn
ihr wollt mache ich gerne mal seine
worte sondern kinder überraschungsei in
xxl
und dann kann man ja das kommt mini
überraschungseier darin verstecken
können einmal abstimmen
[Musik]
sieht schon mal super auf was jetzt noch
fehlt sind hier am rand so ganz kleine
stücke die fülle ich jetzt einfach damit
auf das heißt ich schneit es hier so ein
bisschen durch und clips mit etwas
ganache an
[Musik]
jetzt darf die torte erstmal in die
kühlung das heißt setzte jetzt hier auf
den torten retter ich dachte mir was
machst du heute meine kleine oster torte
okay vielleicht wahrscheinlich dafür 20
leute also wenige kleider machen wollt
dann packt einfach natürlich kleinere
kuchen kleiner durchmesser und eine
kleinere platte und die kommt jetzt für
etwa 30 bis 40 minuten im kühlschrank
bis die ghanaer schon fest wird die
torte kann sich noch mal schön setzen
und anschließend wird sie dann schön
zugeschnitten
in der zwischenzeit mache ich noch mal
eine portion weise gerne stellen die
wird mir jetzt nicht ausreichen und
räume hier auf und später zeige ich euch
noch wie wir die resteverwertung an
jetzt ist es schön fest und ich kann es
zu schneiden also ich kann es hier
erstmal außen mich an dieser schablone
orientieren
das heißt nicht so viel wegschneiden und
dann versuche ich das ganze einfach
rundlich zu machen und so der höhepunkt
der sollte ich hier ungefähr sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie zieht man ungefähr ganz gut die form
jetzt habe ich hier natürlich noch
lücken die möchte ich jetzt nicht mit
ghanas füllen das wäre einfach etwas zu
viel
deswegen habe ich ja hier noch ein
bisschen zeit übrig und so lege ich mir
jetzt einfach ein paar stücke immer
drauf macht die creme drunter also die
gas strömte kann es dann nochmal zu
schneiden und man kann auch die torte
immer wieder zwischendurch kühl stellen
so kann die garage ankleben und dann
haben wir daran arbeiten
[Musik]
also ich finde das jetzt so ganz gut das
wird aber viel deko was ist jetzt noch
mal alles okay was ich gezwungen werde
ich werde jetzt erstmal eine schicht
gerne streicheln so werden diese krümmel
hier gebunden
dann stelle ich die torte kühl und
strich sind danach noch mal schön
komplett glatt bei der ersten geschichte
ist wirklich gut wenn die garage noch
etwas flüssiger ist bei der zweiten
schicht bei der ganz klappen schlechter
darf dann ruhig bis im fester sein
brauchst so lecker aus ok dieses große
baby kommt jetzt in den kühlschrank und
darf jetzt fest werden und ich meine die
zweite schicht die kann man dann gleich
klappt denn die torte so schon fast
richtig glatt kann es muss erst mal fest
werden gott will wird die torte
als wären gerade nebenher pläne aber ich
habe jetzt hier dieses iphone app
gestrichen
willkommen im kühlschrank und dann hole
ich weiß und fondant und kneten schon
mal schön weich oder noch verschiedene
farben aber das sei wirklich jetzt schön
glätten komplett mit einer teil karte es
war kein kleines durcheinander bei uns
in der kirche aber alles okay und schön
kühl stellen und in der zwischenzeit den
ganzen von land vorbereiten
[Musik]
okay ich hab sie nicht schlecht aus ok
hab mit dir in den kühlschrank wir
kneten jetzt weißen von land und dann
noch farbigen von dann muss ich weiß
auch nicht so starke hände hat ja gesagt
hätten
guten tag liebe nur chinesen ok keine
komischen ich würde jetzt sagen dass wir
heute zum walter großen gekriegt aber da
weiß jeder dass wir zwei monate vor
ostern schon dort war okay
wir wussten ja nicht wie lange ist ein
brauch deswegen wir sind schon drei tage
trauer an vonlanthen
ja jetzt keine einzelnen tragen und grün
blauen ins tor genau und damit die
farben bisschen fast elliger werden
machen wir überall noch ein bisschen
weit sein
hier wollen wir auch ein hellblau kann
man am besten das weiß erst kneten und
dann mit dem blau verkneten
ja weil es ist 16.30 uhr das noch nicht
überzogen mit moment warum weil weil
alle nur quatsch machen
du hast und gestricktes quasi die in der
schule die hinten gesessen hat und alle
andere stimme mit papier fügte wer will
eigentlich sogar endlich mal weltmeister
die größere aber noch nichts zu hören
aber wir führen dies mit kapitän a ha
jetzt hinweist von dann wird er das
beckert stärke dünn ausrollen und den
ziehe ich dann einmal über die gesamte
torte
[Musik]
jetzt besprüht die torte mit etwas back
greenspan so als haftmittel zwischen
fondant und torte und legt die front und
der cats drauf perfekt und dann einfach
hier kurz glätten und den überschuss mit
einem marzipan messer wegschneiden denn
das smart meter ist ein stumpfes messer
könnte auch von den heißen und damit
lässt sich gut wegschneiden ohne dass er
eben den von dann zerreißt
[Musik]
kommt jetzt so in den kühlschrank und
ich werde die anderen farben die schon
vorbereitet habe dünn ausrollen und
kleine und große kreise ausstechen und
ich habe immer im kopf das ist wirklich
ein schöner farbverlauf wird ich hoffe
es klappt aber ich setze ist hier gleich
noch auf eine saubere unterlage und dann
wird es nochmal ausgerollt
[Musik]
und jetzt stelle ich hier große und
kleine kreise aus das heißt ich glaube
ich mache zwei größen
[Musik]
das ist mein um 20 das heißt hier ist
die hälfte
und dann drittel ist okay ich fange
jetzt unten an und klebt es hier unten
mit essbarem kleber den irgendwo
versteckt hat wo es in der klimaschutz
und klebe jetzt hier diese punkte an
fangen jetzt mal mit lila an unten also
ein bisschen kleber auf den kreis und
dann mache ich jetzt erstmal eine linie
und stehe jetzt immer einen großen punkt
und dann in kleinen punkt daneben
[Musik]
o
und bei der zweiten reihe kommen einfach
die kleinen kreise unter die großen und
eben genau andersrum
man fühlt sich hier praktisch so die
lücke und es guckt nur noch ein bisschen
weiß durch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das alles natürlich fertig also sagen
normalerweise ist hier die küche immer
ordentlich aber ganz ehrlich wenn wir so
500 kreise ausstechen
dann sieht ungefähr so aus vor allem
wenn es schon 18 uhr am abend ist sie
schon seit 8 uhr 18.30 uhr okay wir
brauchen erstmal zehn angefangen aber
egal
ja wo jetzt mache ich hier kurz sauber
und dann probieren wir die trotz
[Musik]
wie findet ihr das 3d ist richtig cool
aus es war fehler habe ich dadurch
vielleicht eine nation wie buchstabiert
man meyer große und kleine eier ist das
war der beste
doch das war die beste art die jemals
gehört habe
ok dann schneiden vielleicht je tonne so
amt naja dann gucken wir mal rein okay
wie es da drinnen auch immer gespannt
ist das war echt viel arbeit ich bin
auch noch mehr putzen nicht werde ich
eigentlich gleich die fleißarbeit
das ist schon eine richtige fleißarbeit
aber es ist auch richtig so oder so eine
arbeit so für eine bewerbung sein
bewährungshelfer hague lebt mal 500
punkte auf 1 3 d es tut mir auch echt
ein bisschen leid ist ein jetzt
anzuschneiden ich mache jetzt extra noch
sauber das meiste damit der anschnitt
schild wird wir haben folgt ist cool
video gemacht wird dann noch schnecke ja
die frida die kleine schnecke aha du
holst dir aber gleich parat die sich ja
witzig hatte erwarte ich zeige mich die
andere seite
da war ein anderer warte ich mache es
kurz so hier sieht man nämlich die
förderung da war ich gerade die
anschlussstelle will die armee zuerst
probieren oder bis zum papa hat die
kinder probieren immer ausnahmen vom
land darf ich zuerst probieren ist hier
also in der mitte musste probieren mal
weiß ob ich lasse jetzt zuerst die ich
probieren und wenn nichts passiert da
ist der papa auch sie mussten ihren hut
du wirst mal auszuprobieren immer von
land probieren
mir schmeckt das kriegt von ella in
meinem buch ist gut also wenn ich die
taten waren wollte an ostern mixa kennt
weder in der größe oder etwas kleiner
das könnt ihr natürlich selbst
entscheiden macht sie gerne nach ihr
könnt natürlich auch ein ganz anderes
muster machen sobald ihr die torte mit
fordern überzogen habt könnt ihr zum
beispiel auch was drauf mal mit
lebensmittelfarben oder man kann so ein
band und der schleife drum herum machen
oder auch so ein spiel nicht mein
gedanke aber dann dachte ich die farben
das wird bestimmt genial
also habe ich das gemacht ja also viel
spaß beim nachmachen heute für unsere
extrem langer dritter wie heute war noch
lange dauert es ungefähr so als wenn
morgen um 10 angefangen mit fast 19 uhr
aber wir müssen dazu sagen ich muss
immer moderationen machen usw
wir haben zwischendurch noch produkte
gedacht da war zwischendurch blau kopf
dann noch mal draußen an der wand fotos
gemacht dann ja und wer machen ja immer
sauber zwischendurch also ich denke wenn
man die böden vor backt am vortrag ist
mein vier bis fünf stunden fertig auf
jeden fall als vorstandschef
aber nicht so viel lässt
das ist jetzt auch für 32 glaube für 20
leute ich hab sie etwas übertrieben mehr
als das reich gottes reich das reicht
nicht aus der küche laufen abspülen
nachts machen ihr die zwei männer
[Musik]
o
auch jetzt noch mal alle pinto macht 81
23 diese stolze 2 kameramann jan o wir
warten draußen marcel fürs gruppenfoto
ok dann würde ich mal sagen film ab
so schön war verließ welt noch nie
einmal zum vergleich hieß es das
original das sage ich jetzt was sie
stört bei der bio sie schwarz jetzt die
200 gramm co
[Musik]
merkt ihr euch mal 50 kilogramm plus
[Gelächter]
jetzt wirklich 74 was wiegt das sei mein
gott ist das schwer
74 hier zu vergessen was ich mit 74 2
minus
[Musik]
die oster torte wiegt zehn kilo kannst